I'm having my breakfast
but I wanted to talk about something as a homeschool parent
that I think really helped me make the switch from doing public school to doing
um like private home education
before starting this video
I would like to acknowledge and admit
that being able to homeschool your children is a privilege um
and especially a financial privilege
it is a privilege of time and resources that a lot of people do not have
and public education is an absolute cornerstone to a free thinking society
and I do not think public education should go anywhere
what I do think however
is that public education needs an update
the system needs to be updated
it hasn't been updated in decades
and honestly our public education system could be so much better
but we all know the powers that we don't wanna do that
anyway back to homeschooling
my older kids went to a Reggio Amelia program for preschool and pre K
and my youngest who's two right now currently goes to a Reggio program
and there is so much science behind child LED
collaborative learning that breeds creative thinking
it breeds problem solving
it breeds collaboration
and it instills a love of learning
because it is so much more child centered than it is curriculum structured
now if we're looking at the class economics of this
these are always private programs and expensive
there's a whole discussion to be had about why
the best forms of learning are kept for
the socioeconomical elite
it's not hard to figure out
so when I started thinking about homeschooling my older kids
one of the biggest benefits I saw to it
was having a much more child LED approach
fostering their love of learning
through allowing them to deep dive into things that they are interested in
while still contributing to their education in the core required step subjects
you know I'm not an unschooler per se
we have curriculum that we use
but I absolutely want my kids to be excited and engaged
and passionate about all the different subjects that we're learning
because in my opinion
sitting through the motions
going through your classes doesn't actually breathe learning at all
how many of us stared off into space
or zoned our teacher out because we were not engaged with the subject matter
so when people say that homeschooling is a good option
I agree I think homeschooling fills the gap that we have in our education system
to allow for child LED and child engaged learning
however I believe that that should be accessible for all children
who would benefit from learning that way
and I don't think it would be impossible
for the American education system to adopt a Reggio Amelia
or even a montessori type method of education
but they won't because it leads to kids asking too many questions